-Welcome back.
-Hey, thanks, man.
-Ever since I heard
about this film,
I've been incredibly excited
to see it.
-It's exciting.
It's an exciting endeavor.
-So, It's a satire.
You play a Nazi.
-Yes.
-There is a young boy
who is a Nazi youth.
He has an imaginary friend
who is Adolf Hitler.
And we can tell from the clip,
you're sort of a bumbling --
You're sort of a buffoon
of a Nazi.
-Yes. I'm a disillusioned
ex-war hero,
who's sort of now
become a buffoon.
He's lost his eye
and he's been demoted
to teaching the Hitler Youth
how to fight.
-I think based on sort of th
dead silence of the audience
there's a fear when you make
a comedy that includes
Nazis and Hitler.
They might be a little worried
-Yeah, yeah.
-But this is also a very -
I mean, it's in very safe hands.
-Yes.
-A fantastic writer and
director.
And it's also a very sweet
story, as well.
-It is very sweet.
And it's very much anti-Hitler
-Yeah.
-I can assure you.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There we go.
-Yes.
Alright.
Let's hear it for anti-fascism
Yes, so, you can be assured,
it's a funny
but, yet, poignant film.
-And it -- You know,
I think it's always exciting
when a film comes out that i
unlike anything
that's come before it,
certainly in this day and age,
and so that's what's
so cool about it.
You mentioned you
are missing an eye --
your character --
so you had to wear a contact
-I had to wear a contact.
Taika had to wear contacts
And, occasionally,
we couldn't wear the contact
'cause of debris and gunfire
or we're in a swimming poo
or something.
But, yeah, when I first go
the -- I couldn't -- I didn't --
I've never --
Have you worn contacts?
I've never worn contacts.
-You know, this is a true story.
And, by the way, this is going
to be very in line
with what we're talking abou
that's hard to laugh at.
I played -- On "SNL," I played
Osama bin Laden once.
-You did?
-There you go.
So I raise your Hitler.
And -- But I didn't --
I'd never --
I'd never in my life
worn contacts,
but Lorne, between
dress and hair, was like,
"We can't have a blue-eyed
Osama bin Laden."
And I said,
"I really don't want --"
-CGI, man.
-Yeah.
I was like, "Come on. It's live.
You can CGI in real time."
So, how was your
contact experience?
-Well, it was interesting,
because the first person -
They have to get,
you know, somebody who knows
what they're doing to put it in.
In fact, I wore some for "SNL,
and I had to get somebody
to put it in,
and it fell out at one point
We had to find it and put it -
But somebody came by, a guy,
and I felt bad for him,
but he was kind of --
He was putting it in like this
-Oh, he had --
-Yeah.
And I was like, "Okay. Hey
Let's take, you know,
a five-minute break,
and we'll, you know -- And we'll
do it again
in like 10 minutes.
And He came back, and it
was more of this kind of thing
And then I was like,
"Alright, yeah,
we're going to
take another break."
And then we got
somebody else to do it.
-You know, you are, as we said
playing a Nazi in this.
And you've played some racists
over the years
in some stuff --
"Three Billboards,"
"Green Mile."
-Yes, yes.
-You know, I know you to b
a lovely person.
Do you feel like you've hi
your cap on those?
-I've hit my cap
on racists for sure.
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
I mean, somebody's got to
play them,
but I'm done with that.
-Yeah, I feel like you've
filled your quota
and you do a great job
and you did a great servic
for all of us.
It was -- And, so,
I saw you at the Emmys.
-Yeah. Yeah, we had fun.
-We had really good time.
-Well, we went back to tha
weird V.I.P. chocolate roo
with booze and chocolate.
-Yeah, it was like --
I'm going to get the name of
the chocolate company wrong, and
I feel like they sponsored it,
so I don't want to even guess.
But, yeah, there was a tiny,
little bar in the back.
If you were about to present
you got to go back there.
And then once we realized
you didn't have to
go back to your seat, we kind of
just hung out there and drank.
-And just hang out there.
Everybody --
Michael Douglas was there.
Colbert.
-Corden. Hader.
It was a good group.
And you were very --
Now, that was after,
I believe, you had lost.
-I had lost. I had, yes.
I was going for
chocolate and booze.
-Yeah. In the beginning of
the night, though,
you were very relaxed.
This is actually in the theater.
So, the night had just started
and you already
took your shoes off.
-Well, the shoes
were kind of brand-new,
and they were pinching a little,
so I took them off
and try and relax
before the ceremony.
-You seemed very laid back
so it definitely worked.
And robbed.
By the way, a great category
-Thanks, thanks.
-Anyone in that category
was deserving.
-It was an amazing group.
-Yeah, an amazing group.
-And "Fosse/Verdon"
was obviously --
Bob Fosse was a role
you had to prepare for,
a lot of rehearsal.
I know you had to,
you know, also, like,
just physically train.
You took spin classes?
Was that something
you've done before?
-I took spin classes
in addition to -- I did.
I did a lot of things --
hot yoga, dance,
a lot of dance, obviously.
Me and Michelle
were dancing quite a bit.
And, but, yes, I did some
SoulCycle classes.
Yeah, I did.
-How was it?
-It was good.
I did one in L.A.
And, you know, sometimes,
you'll see some people --
I saw Usher once,
in the -- next to me.
And he was lovely.
He gets after it, you know
-Yeah.
-Was he intimidating?
Was he so good --
-No, he was cool.
I think, at one point, I was -
You know, you ever done
SoulCycle?
-I've never done it, no.
-It's kind of claustrophobic
But it's a good workout.
You put the earplugs in,
and you're doing --
And there's a weight series,
and you got to put
the resistance up.
And I think I stopped pedaling
and he was like,
"Hey, man, come on."
And, yeah, but I've seen him
He gets after it.
-It is always so great
to see you.
And, again, I want everybody
to see this movie,
because it is such a cool thing.
-It's really cool.
It's really cool.
-And thank you so much
for being here, as always.
-Thanks for having me, man
-Sam Rockwell, everybody.